منافسه محتدمه متوقعا تشهدها انتخابات
الرئاسه التركيه الاحد القادم اربعه
مرشحين تم اعتمادهم الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان وكمال كالجدار اوغلو ومحرم انجي
وسنان اونان وبينما تتجه الانظار وتنشغل
العقول في نتائج تلك الانتخابات على
الجانب الاخر تحتد المنافسه بين مرشحين
اثنين اردوغان ومنافسه الابرز كالجدار
اوغلو حرب من التصريحات والفيديوهات
نشهدها بين المرشحين وبين انصار كل منهما
ويبدو ان التسميه الاصح لتلك المنافسه هي
حرب البصل والبطاطا او ديمقراطيهما فبينما
يخاطب اردوغان انصاره بالوعود التجاريه
والمشاريع الاستثماريه يخاطب منافسه
كالجدار اوغلو انصاره بالبصل والبطاطا
والحياه المعيشيه في الاول يعد بانفتاح
على العالم وتطور اقتصادي ونمو تجاري
والاخر يعد بتحسين الحياه المعيشيه وتخفيض
تكاليفها فاردوغان
ظهر منذ ايام بين انصارهم متحديا منافسه
ووافقا من شعبيته وقال لانصاره انه متاكد
انهم لن يبيعوه من اجل البطاطة والبصل
انقضت ايام حتى جاء الرد من انصار منافسه
كالجدار اوغلو الذين شاركوا الاخير فيديو
كان قد نشره في اتر الماضي
ظهر خلاله وهو يتكلم عن السياسه
الاقتصاديه الهشه للرئيس اردوغان وحزب
العداله والتنميه والتي اقحمت البلاد في
ازمه اقتصاديه كبرى واستشهد في الفيديو
ببصله حقيقه الناس محتاره بين ان تختار
البصل والبطاطا ام الاسلحه والاستث
مار
الحرب بين انصار كل من اردوغان وكل جدار
اوغلو تعدت مواقع التواصل وصلت الى ارض
الواقع فتعرض رئيس بلديه اسطنبول المعارض
اكرم امام اوغلو والذي يعتبر من داعمي
منافس اردوغان الابرز كمال
تعرض خلال خطاب مع تجمع لانصار اوغلو في
ولايه اردن الى رشق بالحجاره من قبل
مجهولين استطاعوا منعه من اكمال الخطاب
[موسيقى]
اما رده فعل بلديه اردوغرم على ما حدث
فكانت باصدار بيان قالت فينا اكرم امام
اوغلو لم يخبرهم بانه قادم لالقاء خطاب
ضمن تجمع لانصاره وانما اخبرهم انه قادم
بجوله في الاسواق وللقاء تجاري هناك اما
سليمان صويلو وزير الداخليه فكتب في
تغريده ان اكرم امام اوغلو شخص استفزازي
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول الدكتور سمير صالحه
الاستاذ في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور سمير
اهلا بك معنا في تفاعلكم في العربيه
الملفت توجه مرشح انتخابي
اللدود اردوغان الى مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لشن حمله تفاعليه ان صح التعبير
ضده مستغلا تصريحات مثيره للجده الجديده
لاردوغان هذه المراه عن البصل والبطاطا
كيف تقيمون هذا التوجه
صحيح مساء الخير للجميع اولا يعني اتفق
معك عامل السوشيال ميديا هذه المره سيكون
له تاثير مختلف عن المرات السابقه في
التعامل مع الانتخابات التركيه سواء كان
على مستوى الانتخابات البرلمانيه او
الرئاسيه لماذا لانه عامل الشباب كما يبدو
دخل بشكل مباشر على الخط يعني المحرك
الاول او الاساسي في السوشيال ميديا في
تركيا الان وبشكل عام ايضا هو الشباب
الذين تطرحوا اعمارهم بين 18 و 25 وهي
كتله بشريه مهمه الان في تركيا حوالي 12
مليون
في هذه الشريحه
يشكلون ثقل اساسي من ارقام الانتخابات
التركيه بشكل عام حوالي 64 مليون ناخب
سيذهب الى الصناديق يوم الاحد المقبل
بينهم هذه الشريحه التي تصل الى 12 و13
وهذه الفئه الان نعم 13 مليون ناخر من جيل
الشباب او جيل زاد على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي كما باتا يعرف يعني من فئه 18
الى 25 سنه هؤلاء كما قلتهم 13 مليون ناخذ
في تركيا بينهم 6 ملايين ناخب يصوتون لاول
مره في تركيا لاي مدى هذا الجيل وهذه
القاعده الانتخابيه ستكون مفتاح الحسم وقد
تقول للتغيير في هذه الانتخابات
صحيح انا رايي الشخصي كما قلت لك قبل قليل
سيكون لها دور مهم اذا ما ذهبت الى
الصناديق لكن المشكله مع هذه الشريحه انه
قبل اشهر كانت تذهب بمنحان المقاطعه
الانتخابات عدم الذهاب الى الانتخابات
لاكثر من سبب يعني بين الاسباب التي
دفعتها في السابق الى اعتماد موقف من هذا
النوع هي عدم ثقتها بالاحزاب السياسيه
بالقيادات السياسيه انها ستعطيها ما تريد
من ضمانات في المرحله المقبله لكن يبدو لي
انه في الاسابيع الاخيره على ضوء ما
سمعناه في الحملات الانتخابيه وهذا وهذا
الشحن والتعبئه الميدانيه براييه سيدفع
هذه الشريحه للمشاركه في هذه العمليه
الانتخابيه هي لها مطالب كثيره اساسيه هذه
الفئه كيف سيتم التعامل معها في المرحله
المق انا اظن انه هذه الفئه ايضا نعم
قادره على التاثير في رسم
النتائج شئنا ام ابينا لماذا لانه كثير من
القيادات السياسيه والاحزاب وضعت في
برامجها في حملاتها الانتخابيه مسائل
باتجاه هذه الفئه بشكل مباشر بينها ضمانات
في مجال التعليم في موضوع العمل في موضوع
ضمانات اجتماعيه
وغيرها لذلك هذه المره برايي نعم هذه
الفئه تكون قلت في الفترات الماضيه هذه
الفئه كانت تتوجه نحو مقاطعه الانتخابات
احدث استطلاعات الراي في تركيا اوضحت ان
فئه الشباب الذين يحق لهم التصويت هذه
المره سيتوجهون للتصويت لصالح المعارضه ضد
حزب العداله والتنميه بسبب انهم ذاقوا
درعا من ارتفاع نسبه البطاله وصلت الى 24%
بين فئه الشباب من هذا العمر وكذلك تدهور
مستوى الوعيشه وذاق درعا من وعود الحكومه
كيف تنظر لهذا التوجه
نعم استطلاعات الراي الكثير من استطلاعات
الرايب
ذهبت باتجاهين كما قلت لك قبل قليل اما
انها ستقاطع الانتخابات
واما انها ستذهب باتجاه دعم مساله التغيير
ترفع شعار التغيير في تركيا مشكله هذه
الشريحه الاهم انه كما اشرتي انت ايضا قبل
قليل حوالي 6 مليون شخص منهم سيذهب الى
الصناديق للمره الاولى انها لا تعرف
الاحزاب الاحزاب التركيه الاخرى غير حزب
العداله والتنميه لماذا الحزب العداله
والتنميه في السلطه منذ العام 2002 وهذه
الفئه لم تختبر لم تعايش احزاب سياسيه
اخرى في السلطه لذلك هي متمسكه بالتغيير
بالتجديد بان ترى احزاب بديله غير حزب
العداله والتنميه هل يكون لها ما تريد
نقطه اولى نقطه ثانيه هل يعني نذهب وراء
استطلاعات الراي انه فئه كبيره من هذا من
عنصر الشباب ست ذهب فعلا وراء دعم التغيير
ام لا هذه ايضا مساله برايي مسائل احد او
صباح الاثنين المقبل سنعرف الكثير من
الاجابات حولها طيب دكتور بالرجوع الى
تصريحات الرئيس التركي باختصار والمثيره
للجلد دائما رجب طيب اردوغان الى اين قد
يتوجه بالفعل ناخب التركي نحو البطاطا
والبصل ام الاستثمار بالاسلحه
البطاطا والبصل كما تعرفين انت ايضا جزء
من نقاشات الاقتصاد في داخل التركي من
ارقام المعيشه ارقام التضخم ارقام الغلاء
هذه المعادله اولى في كفه نقطه مهمه تشرين
اليها لكن بالمقابل في عنا في الكفه
الثانيه مساله
المشاريع الاستراتيجيات التي انجزها حزب
العداله والتنميه سواء كان في موضوع
الطاقه في موضوع الغاز في موضوع انجازات
حملت المسيرات وغيرها من المشاريع
الاستراتيجيه المهمه لذلك قرار الناخب
الان سيكون بين الكفتين يعني باتجاه
التغيير واتجاه التركيز على موضوع
الاقتصاد وارقام المعيشه وطال الاولويه ام
يعني الذهاب وراء الحكومه الحزب الحاكم في
الرهان على انه المشاريع الاستراتيجيه هي
اهم من ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك من اسطنبول
الدكتور سمير صالحه الاستاذ في العلاقات
الدوليه شكرا دكتور
[موسيقى]